ja die epoche zeitenwende in der wir uns
sicherheitspolitisch befinden besteht
einfach darin dass man erstmalig seit
1945 die situation hat dass ein land ein
nachbarland überfallen wird
und das hat natürlich immense
auswirkungen letztlich auf unsere
sicherheitspolitik das ist eine zäsur
wie 89 damals ende des kalten krieges
und heute ist es eben so dass wir damit
in eine komplett neue zeit gehen wir
müssen uns überlegen wie stellt sich die
nato jetzt auf wir haben ja damals in
den 90er jahren die senator russland
grund aktie gemacht mit russland wir
haben geregelt dass wir in den
osteuropäischen bündnis
ländern keine permanenten streitkräfte
stationieren rotierende verbände auch
nicht so ausgestattet wie es optimal
wäre für die vorne verteidigung dass
alle steht zur disposition
wir wissen ja auch nicht was putin
danach macht nicht es steht nur fest
dass wir in den appetit auf mehr
unbedingt nehmen müssen wenn die
baltischen staaten zb waren auch mal bei
sowjetrepubliken haben auch russische
minderheit und er könnte mit dem
gleichen drehbuch wie in georgien mit
südossetien nach asien mit dem was in
der ukraine könnte er sehr schnell auch
mit lettland operieren und wie
verhindern wir dass das ist die große
frage und wie ist der deutsche beitrag
wir haben erstmalig für die bundeswehr
eine wahnsinnige finanzspritze nicht die
bundeswehr ist faktisch aber nicht
einsatzbereit wenn wir eine andere
situation heute wären wie die ukraine
wir konnten uns gar nicht wehren und ich
sehe auch nicht den deutschen
patriotismus und die kämpfer die bereit
wären in den untergrund zu gehen und so
ein konflikt durchzuziehen das heißt wir
müssen unseren mindset also komplett
ändern und glaube das ist ganz
entscheidend neben den ganzen
materiellen dingen die wir jetzt
umsetzen müssen um die bundeswehr
einsatz bereit zu kriegen aber das wird
auch jahre dauern und das ist wirklich
eine ganz krasse zäsur in der wir uns
befinden eine zeitenwende weder
bundeskanzler scholz auch richtigerweise
sagt
ich hab ich glaube sei er auch
praktische fragen sie meine in dunkler
wird sehr oft
windschutz des himmels gesprochen und
der ukraine zum beispiel sagen
eigentlich auf dem lande können wir
selber dann die russische soldaten
bekämpfen sehen sie die möglichkeit das
vielleicht durch die nato oder
vielleicht auch andere staaten möglich
wäre den beitrag zu dem schutz des
himmels zu zeichnen zu leisten damit die
raketen nicht einfach auf sie wieder
objekte
abgeschossen werden lassen seine frage
jetzt auch in dir diskutiert wurde die
die der
ukrainische präsident ja auch brachte
mit der
flugverbotszone
das ist natürlich schwierig wir haben
die angewandt auf dem balkan im irak und
das kann man eigentlich nur machen wenn
man als eine starke militärkoalition ist
gegenüber einem wesentlich schwächeren
herausforderer oder gegner der ein paar
flieger hat ein paar hubschrauber hat
aber hier haben wir russland als
weltmacht das heißt der einstieg in so
eine flugverbotszone konsequent
betrachtet wäre der einstieg in einen
krieg und das ist genau der punkt wo ich
selber drüber nachdenke wir wollen
offensichtlich ja nicht diesen kriegs
konflikt diesen dritten weltkrieg und
diesen atomar krieg mit russland das ist
glaube ich einhellige meinung der aller
nato partner wird einerseits solidarisch
mit der ukraine wir wollen noch helfen
aber wir wollen nicht in den krieg rein
und das ist so ein bisschen schwierig
möchten auch die abschreckungsstrategie
funktioniert ja noch nur wenig
glaubwürdig machen kann dass ich auch
zum krieg bereit bin wenn der andere
weiß krieg ist ausgeschlossen dann ist
man ein abschreckungs wert gleich null
welche andererseits ist es
wahrscheinlich rational nachvollziehbar
vernünftig dass man nicht damit in einem
dritten weltkrieg rutscht das ist genau
das problem und das dilemma und was
putin anbelangt natürlich auch wenn ich
am ende dann doch das ganze regeln muss
was er da jetzt macht in der ukraine
da muss sich irgendwann ab einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt auch bereit sein
mit ihm wieder zu reden
moshe dayan hat das mal gemacht gesagt
den ich sehr schätze toller israelischer
general der auch ein super außenminister
war er hat mal gesagt wenn du frieden
willst reicht es nicht aus mit deinen
freunden zu reden du musst mit deinen
feind reden welche und wir müssen diese
option ich bin kein cannabis nennt man
muss stärke zeigen knallharte stärke
grenzen aufzeigen
muss ließen diesen aspekt offen halten
sonst sind wir im krieg eine eine
einzige zwischenfrage dann würde ich
gleich auch noch mal in folge wie wir
denn mit den feinen sprechen können
glauben sie das ist jetzt wieder ein
wortspiel ein was wäre gewesen wenn
spielt wenn frau merkel noch kanzlerin
wäre bei der thematik abschreckung
stärke zeigen dass putin krieg gewagt
hätte ich bin mir ich bin mir da nicht
sicher ich glaube es hat ihm den job aus
seiner sicht erleichtert dass sie nicht
mehr da war denn sie hatte ihm schon den
marsch geblasen das hat sie bei anderen
dingen auch gemacht und ich habe das ja
oft bei gesprächen erlebt dass er sie
schon sehr
respektiert hat also und ein stück weit
auch
akzeptiert hat so wie sie war trotz der
ganzen gegensätze die sie auch hatte und
sie hat ihm schon das leben ziemlich
schwer gemacht und hat ihm schon gezeigt
was sie von seinem ganzen aktionen
hielten ich aber sie hat trotzdem diese
gesprächskanäle gehabt und ich halte das
so schwer dass im moment fällt also wir
brauchen beides das ist letztlich auch
das gesamte rational der nato seit dem
bestehen gewesen dass wir immer gesagt
haben setzt auf abschreckung und stärke
auf härte und hier und nicht weiter und
gleichzeitig auf die bereitschaft zum
dialog und das müssen wir machen dann
werden wir den dialog wegnehmen das ende
des dialogs ist der beginn des krieges
war wie siehst du das ende des dialogs
dialog mit den feinden wie es das
derzeit aktuell möglich das fragen sich
ja auch wirklich viele
ich halte es für sehr illusorisch leider
natürlich wäre es gut wenn es
verhandlungen geben aber erstens bleibt
und ist putin einen lügner zweitens gibt
es nichts was er auf den tisch legen
kann der herzlicher festgelegt aus
seiner sicht ist die ukraine russland
wie soll man darüber verhandeln da fehlt
mir jegliche fantasie und vor allem auch
in der frage wie der ukrainische
präsident darauf reagieren soll denn
alles was putin dort auf den tisch legen
würde und sie lenski unterschreiben
würde würde hier wir haben gerade über
den patriotismus gesprochen zu einem
bürgeraufstand führen wahrscheinlich
dann zu einem bürgerkrieg was auch immer
und man würde wütend werden zu recht auf
seinen ski also das ist eine vase die
schwierige situation sowohl für den
ukrainischen präsidenten als auch für
das gesamte land
und der frage wie man da rauskommt und
ich sehe momentan nicht was auf
irgendeine art von möglichkeit hindeutet
dass es zu einem schnellen frieden
kommen können
wir sind leider schon fast am ende zehn
sekunden antwort frau wenig schaum
müssen uns die frage stellen werden wir
uns damit abfinden dass der ukrainer
templates an bord wird und die werden
wir damit leben